well I was going to ask you like uh I do
think that at times in Latin hip hop it
feels like because there isn't like a
super popping Mexican rapper nationally
yet that when someone starts to pop the
Divide starts to happen I don't care
about I'm just like let me finish my let
me finish my point let me finish so like
like an example would be like uh the
homie from Houston that Mexican OT he's
hard he ain't Cali popping like he just
sold out the no he's in Houston popping
he's the best rapper in Houston he he's
the best raer but let me finish my my
bad before I say it no no no I got to
get out the way cuz I already spoke on
him like I'm talking [__] about him no
he's the best rapper and everybody says
he's the best rapper before I forget my
bad it's his podcast I just want to get
it right cuz they're going to twist it
nah hell no I want to feature with him
that's my dream collab he's the best
rapper I never seen nobody spit the way
he does he's not even real homie my
point was no but I just want to get it
out the way before it goes on it and be
like I'm talking [__] on no you're
saying something positive about it yeah
he hard he's super hard he hard and I
can't wait to go out to the Houston okay
my bad now your point your no my point
was that I I noticed that now that he's
starting to pop that's a viral moment we
got to edit that [__] I should have done
that there's a whole lot of negative
energy from the other Mexican artists in
Texas towards him and I feel like a lot
of times in La whenever um a Mex artist
starts to pop everybody starts turning
turning against them like I saw I like
this I like this well I saw this happen
with like Kook and CNG like they beefed
out when they would have been better
being together like I mean you know what
I'm saying like I want to get it already
like to me if you think of uh you're
you're on fire I love crook shout out
crook one man yeah I know you guys work
together for sure my boy but what I'm
saying is like I feel like for the sake
of like putting on a Mexican for the
United States as a rapper it's like the
the unity's got to be there oh GG
oh exactly OG and if you notice ogz
don't
like he's always he's always extremely
positive you don't ever see him wrapped
up in any of the negative [__] shout out
to O we got a song together man he
worldwide man you cannot say you never
heard he the best but my question to you
main with it is that something you think
about like let me try to kind of like no
no uhuh at all I always keep it real to
myself you like it cool you don't fast
forward I just mean in terms of like
trying to no I got to I got to go
mainstream but I don't give a damn like
I just want to do it from make music cuz
I love to make music I don't want nobody
to Tain or change my steo and it does
happen you dis a certain rapper they try
to twist it that way with that Keen
little G incident you know what I'm
saying but I stood solid and I didn't
mean it that way but I do think that I'm
the best and he's the best dog so they
try to twist it they made they whatever
they did that out of it but you got to
get it right like I don't care like I'm
just doing it for La that's what I do
music for for La yeah for La for Los
Angeles cool if they listen to it out of
town cool they feel me I don't care damn
I'm not going to lie to them I make it
for LA La for eday and for blacks I make
la music I want people in La I don't
care about the radio I want people in LA
to get in the car on a Friday and go
bump that lefty gun plate yeah that's
all I care about it's just like making
music where I'm just letting it out
everything I see my raps are real like I
meet a lot of these rappers dude and
they're not like that in real life and
it's like it breaks it breaks your heart
cuz like you look up to them you know
your there's certain ones that are like
you know they're they're like that and
just like now since I'm doing it it's
just like happens so quick and it's just
like it's it's overrated it ain't what I
thought it was it's cool shot I saw the
fans and [__] I'm going to keep making
music but it ain't what it [__] the fame
like you know what I'm saying like
forget the money the money you get the
money is cool whatever I got money you I
I a happy I got a couple I never had a
couple thousand 100,000 in my life you
know I'm saying I touched the 100,000
ghetto fresh nine nine bands I touch 100
touch how you say rapping you ain't even
touch 10,000 I'm touching that it's cool
it's like now what like it's like still
not happy I wonder what the hell it is
and it ain't drugs it ain't being in
jail like I wonder what it is like I
don't know what's going to make me happy
like it's just in motion dog OTR keeps
me like a family dog and like I don't
care about uh any other state but just
LA and just making rap for like the
homies dog and the homies are the main
ones that hate on me dog so that's what
I want to tell you I want to break the
barrier and I don't think it'll ever get
broken just with like the way that the
comments are with Mexicans hating on
Mexicans but like they're so quick to go
and jump and support like and me too I
love black songs you know what I'm
saying I love black art I want I want
songs with black artists black artists
are my favorite but I'm always going to
support a Mexican I I would sign with a
black label I will sign with a Mexican
label I would sign with any label
whatever shout outs to the blacks shout
outs to the Mexicans and La if you know
you know but I'm going to go with a
Mexican artist cuz I want to see the
homie win well there's so many Dope Up
and cominging artists right now there's
you're obviously yourself they're not
they're not breaking that barrier theom
I'm saying I mean but they're on the
come like coyotes dope uh SC hard Bravo
I never heard of him I heard of Bravo
you never heard of coyote the two
brothers never they're hard are they
they're fire I don't know if I'll check
that out I keep it real but I heard of
Bravo the bag Chaser J bans I heard of
Bravo he reached out to me we got a song
together shout out bravo bravo cash you
send that song with Bravo yes sir yeah
we got a song with Bravo and J B we G to
do a song uh it's called Holyfield on
the gang Bravo the back Lefty gum J B
those are like they're they're doing it
they're like Hood Rich I'm curious cuz I
I I noticed like the songs like pick to
rap over like that are old school like
the game start from scratch and Eminem
to Superman freestyle what were you like
growing up bumping like what were what's
your like top three or four favorite
albums of all time um the game the one
with the hater to love it how the
documentary 50 s Richard D try yep and
uh man let me see probably Dr Dre 2001
but if I had a go I would be debating on
it I would probably get a a a Drummer
Boy CD straight out the line that one go
hard in it I'll get a drummer boy CD too
that CD go hard straight out the line
shout out Drummer Boy man D homies I see
go crazy or Mazy one the first one nah I
would get the CML lavage D [__]
heavyweight tank That's my boy I can't
do that I want to with heavyweight tank
more I can't do that it's like somebody
doing a song on my I'm going get it with
heavyweight tank he got some [__] every
day before I get ready I bump that uh a
plane for kees that [__] go crazy and he
[__] excuse my Lang you you wouldn't do
a reg with Mazy I rather do it with CML
okay cuz that's my favorite rapper CML
if I bump his music I would do a song
with Mazy Ma's hard he's one of the
greats in my opinion I wouldn't switch
up though cuz CML reached out to me
first I wouldn't I don't care about the
fame CML and I bump I bump CML just as
much as I bump Mazy but I would rather
ring with CML cuz he just recognize me I
just like I bumping stuff every day
before I go home with just Hood like
that who cares if it's more Moy that's
CML lavish D he go hard you seen his
songs a million you better ask about
your son I put tags on fees my mama text
me she said she praying for me I text my
mama right back you said I'm playing for
kees huh he go crazy that song makes me
want to go do a concert and just like
have you been to Sacramento yet hell no
I going out there on that some with CML
we we a get I'm out of bounds baby on
the gang I ain't going with Chito I
ain't going with them I ain't going
nobody I stay down south I was I was
going to say like if you get booked up
there you going to take the booking or
no I'm taking the straps I'm taking the
straps I ain't going out there I'm way
out of bounds I wouldn't want to even
touch grounds right there oh I wouldn't
people on the blog saying that oh he's
disy nor so what I am disy nor and I
would never go up there I'm not stupid
and you would never come down here well
I've noticed like a lot of the a lot of
the ogs are uniting from the south and
the north I don't want to speak on the
ogs I don't speak on Prison politics
prisons prisons the streets is the
streets but I talk about music we're
talking music wise whatever they got
going hey I I listen to that my politics
are different I don't speak on that so
what I speak on though is music wise
people say northel are better than
Southside rappers this is for music
they're not they're not they're hard I
don't bump none of this stuff you know
what I'm saying and they stay dissing
the homies so why is everybody all but
her that I'm saying [__] them cuz they
stay dissing us you know what I'm saying
they stay dissing us calling us you know
what I'm saying that's cool so each is
his own I'm going to make music from my
side hey shout out to he to world man
Blue Devil I like the way he puts it he
just keeps it real dog and he makes me
see it the way that I see it but I just
can't get the words out but he just like
I would it's a big topic it's everybody
saying left he says I I would never do a
song with them I would never go up there
and go to their side of town and I don't
think they would ever come down south I
never seen a northel oh never mind I'm
not going to say nothing it's another
subject I never I never leave it like
that